a lot of greasy
fatality what's going on there reject
nation
we just finished doing our reaction for
mortal kombat literally
oh my god credits are rolling y'all so
they let us watch it early because
uh we have an interview with the
screenwriter to do which uh
because of recording and uploading blah
blah blah it's probably gonna go up a
little bit after this video goes up
speaking of which we did just shoot a
reaction
so subscribe click the notification bell
to get notified
when our movie reaction you know the
reaction highlights will be up on
youtube
full-length watch along where you sync
up with us we'll be over at our patreon
page as like we did for justice league i
thought it'd be fun to just hop in here
give our quick reaction thoughts to this
movie mortal kombat highly anticipated
john you go first
i i had a lot of fun with this i mean
you could probably see throughout the
reaction i mean these kinds of movies
tend to make me a little bit worried
because uh you know it's hard to adapt a
fighting video game but as far as
these kinds of films go and
acknowledging what has come before with
the original film
i thought they did a pretty nice job
with this i feel like there are certain
things you could still be wanting
especially with the restriction of an
r rating as opposed to anything harder
but for me
i mean i had a lot of fun with the cast
the action the effects and all that
stuff but you know you have a bit more
history with mortal kombat i feel like
so what did you think
yeah i quite enjoyed it i think what you
show up here
for and from anyone who's watched the
trailers and i see it in the comments
all the time that when they go to watch
this movie what they're really looking
for
is some great gore and some exquisite
action scenes some really well
choreographed fight scenes there's like
over 10 plus fights in this a hundred
ten minutes
it's a pretty short movie all things
considered for the the amount of
characters they have in here
and for the amount of scenes they got to
cut around to it's a pretty short movie
and they got
a lot of fight scenes in here and it
just doesn't stop this could be rated r
for non-stop
action because it's like action plot
action block there's like
so much action in here there are some
really gratifying
violent moments yes there are some
fatalities in here without giving it
away
which fatality it is i would say kung
lao probably gets the coolest fatality
of them all yeah that's some pretty
badass stuff
and there are some pretty dynamite
visual effects this does feel a little
bit on the lower budget side of a warner
brothers produced movie
that being said you know like i actually
thought there was some
really you pointing this word exquisite
there's some exquisite visual effects
especially when it comes to characters
like
sub-zero to scorpion goro was a
character too that i was concerned about
being cgi because i was a big fan of the
90s mortal kombat movie i love the
practical effects there but for what
they do with goro in here i'm like no
that needed to be
cgi we recorded a reaction i'm glad we
did because
there are plenty of moments to react to
when it comes to uh
the great storytelling within the fight
scenes themselves
and i love how every character kind of
gets a variety
of the kind of fighting style that they
do as well everything on the technical
side is enjoyable like the music is
especially really cool to listen to like
if you're able to watch us with
headphones on give it a shot in terms of
like favorite characters though because
there are so many characters in here i
felt like everyone did their best to
bring at least personality to the role
hands down though like from the opening
scene like my favorite parts of this
movie are actually the bookends from my
understanding
they released the first seven minutes
online we did not watch the first seven
minutes online
otherwise it would have been a reaction
to it there's more past that first seven
minutes and that whole opening i think
is great the prologue the finale i
really like as a matter of fact i would
say
the first like 45 minutes of this movie
and the last half hour are my favorites
of this film but my favorite characters
uh in terms of like who really had my
heart were scorpion
subzero and surprisingly kano
yeah oh dude josh lost and steals every
scene he's in in this movie like kano
he also probably has the most dialogue
out of anybody just given his
personality but yeah he really shines
and i enjoy kung lao too personally
especially when
he and kano get to kind of butt heads
not to say too much you'll see yeah i
think kano kind of has a bit of like a
jim jeffries vibe about him
immortal combat world yeah absolutely
you know everyone else is cool
uh like the guy plays jax i sympathize
for him quite a bit given the
circumstances of his situation as you
see in the trailer
of all the other characters i felt like
he had the most sort of emotional core
there
liu kang definitely not the lead in this
movie but the guy who plays him
freaking for not knowing his name right
off hand at the moment i love
what they kind of did with the dynamic
and the chemistry between liu kang
and kung lao liu kang is a very much
obedient
disciplinary classic martial arts
character and kung
lao is uh related to him and has more of
a more of an
edge to his personality you know more
cocky a little bit more ego more
straightforward we'll get in your face
will push
a matter of fact one of my favorite just
written character scenes in here
is a scene that involves without giving
stuff away too much
but you know in the trailer you see kano
use a laser it's the first scene where
kano uses a laser there's actually a
really good
dialogue driven provoking scene
revolving around that which i liked a
lot cole young is the main character in
here
lewistown he's got incredible fight
scenes in here the guy has an
action career ahead of him oh yeah sonya
blade is a character that we often kind
of
make fun of in terms of live action like
oh they got the supermodel of course she
did
come across as a very believable woman
who could kick my ass any day of the
week
yeah i believe that they cast somebody
with fight experience not they trained a
attractive actress to fight yeah i
thought she actually
had presents and she actually held her
own there were moments where i felt like
as an ensemble they
shined and there were times where i felt
like it was a little bit lackluster from
being
uh totally honest because you got earth
round for the mortal
fans of mortal kombat you got earth
round then you got outworld and then out
world i didn't really find that stuff
super interesting it actually felt kind
of bland it looked a little bit like
annihilation
when you cut away you start to wonder
like what happens here the rest of the
time what do you guys think
rockstar yeah yeah this just looks like
a desolate place to be
like the costume design and the makeup
and the character look
that always looks great and if you're a
fan of mortal kombat and you want to see
that brought to life i think they do
they bring that to life it's pretty
rewarding to be like damn that looks
right out of the video game that's
awesome but you know if i'm being honest
like there's a part of me that did crave
more character development at the end of
the day like i said at the beginning of
this
what you show up for it's satisfying and
ultimately i left being like
yeah that was super freaking
entertaining yeah that was really
entertaining from beginning to end
very entertaining i did crave a little
bit more though from character which
i know can sound a little bit unfair
when you if you watch like our godzilla
versus
kong discussion for example where we're
like who cares about the people we show
up for the monsters
whereas in that movie to make a quick
comparison it's like yeah you show up
for the monsters in that movie that's
why i don't care about the people
here am i sure enough for fight scenes
yes but i'm also showing up to watch
these characters be brought to life i
don't know why they're fighting
yeah and i i w the trailers might have
you thinking that this movie's probably
a lot about
scorpion versus subzero when it's not
really about that it's more of like a b
story in here that is significant but
it's not the main
focus if that makes sense yeah and i
found myself and maybe this is because
of just who this character scorpion is
maybe because i'm a big fan
of the animated movie scorpion's revenge
i found myself
kind of wishing that they they made that
the main focus of the movie
that because when that was on screen
that's where i thought it actually had
the most sincere
heart as you probably felt in the
opening scene that went online
yeah absolutely i think that's a good
call it's like the rest of the movie
certainly is fun and entertaining but
the plot
elements start to feel a bit more
familiar and a bit more like some of the
90s fodder that is trying to elevate
itself
beyond yeah so yeah there is a certain
element and two like
the involvement of the actual mortal
kombat tournament
is also something that is plugged into
the movie in us
in a way that i wasn't necessarily
expecting without saying too much and
i'm curious to see how fans will react
to
in some ways it feels like a prequel to
mortal kombat i
don't want to give it away but there was
one element to here where i was like
i'm kind of disappointed it didn't go
there
yeah yeah and so like i think this does
succeed at bringing this stuff to life
really well but it does leave a few
areas where it could have been perhaps
more flavorful
or had more yeah like you said character
or even a greater attention to like the
tableaus that you're used to seeing when
fights happen
in the game because this does seem like
a movie that did borrow and hone in on
the game
to make it authentic to that experience
to some degree at least
yeah because by the time you get to act
two the locations become
quite minimal i'll say yeah it's like it
seems like you're hopping around to a
lot then locations become
they there's the stage designs start
feeling a little bit bland or generic
even though you're with the characters
the whole time
and then you get back to some cooler
levels i mean i'm just going to call it
level up because that's what it feels
like
yeah there's a point where you're like
oh it smells like video game levels cool
and that's what i'm saying the first 45
minutes i i thought were
really entertaining even though look i'm
not going to [ __ ] you guys the
dialogue and the character scenes for
the most part
other than the scorpion and sub-zero
moments specifically them
for the most part with all the other
characters it feels incredibly cheesy
like it's corny it's cheesy but it's
entertaining and at times though it can
fall a little bit flat especially around
like the
last half of act two i would say and
because there's also
so much action in this movie that there
does get to a point where you get kind
of
used to how cool it is like there's a
bit of a plateau feeling
that occurs with it i can see that for
for some viewers certainly yeah it's
like yeah it's always great and they
never
slack and the direction especially like
the the camera movements and the
capturing of the action and the
choreography they give it a hundred and
million percent every single time it's
on screen punchy in its production
values yeah
but if the in-between stuff of the
character moments hit
better there's a part to me that i'm
like i like them
but i do i really care about i like them
and i have an investment from the games
and whatnot and from knowing the
characters legacy over the years
but as a plot about characters are they
actually compelling if you took all that
away
exactly because i would say this i'm a
fan of the 90s movie this feels very
different it's obviously more gory
the action is better than the 90s movie
i did feel the 91 had
a bit more that's also a cheesy film but
it also has
more personality to it i think the actor
who played shang tsung
in that 90s movie there's no actor in
here that
matches that caliber of charisma or
screen presence
or christopher lambert or christopher
lambert and i thought
ryden too looked great his aesthetic
looked awesome
but i did feel ryden was underused in
here i feel like what they gave to
kung lao and liu king which i enjoyed i
feel like
was probably gonna be given to ryden
initially like i liked the concept of
what they
started off with writing he's a little
bit he's more cynical than i imagined
him to be
and his aesthetic looks great yeah i do
feel like he's kind of underused because
this is sure it's a short movie
but he got a lot of characters cut
around too all that being said
and i mean this sincerely because i know
we like had a lot of positive say that
we had
a lot of criticisms to say all that
being said i think for
laying the groundwork setting up the
seeds for
a franchise for a part one installment
where you can do a part two
take more time do what you really want
to get expand the runtime
make sure you can really flesh out the
characters that much more and it ends on
a note that gets you excited for a
sequel and i think it ought to get a
sequel i still think it deserves one
regardless
and it was great as someone who is half
asian to see a bunch of asian
representation on screen it was awesome
see and there was one white guy for me
one white guy for jesus
even though i definitely have my
criticisms about it i think it's a great
step in the right direction especially
for video game movies
and it's really freaking it's [ __ ]
entertaining yeah it's entertaining all
right it's
really entertaining they hit the mark
about as much as they needed to and yeah
this seems like a good
solid step in the right direction for
video game movies but still with room to
improve kind of kind of like tomb raider
in the sense of like the alicia vikander
one it's like it does a lot
gets it right could be a little more
unique but you know this is a good start
and i would love
to see a sequel yeah end of the day what
all you guys are saying in the comments
of what you wanted a movie to deliver on
a hundred percent it does and then
there's other stuff around it in terms
of filmmaking and storytelling that you
could criticize
but great first step and i mean that
sincerely keep a lookout for our
reaction to go up on youtube cause trust
me there's plenty of
super entertaining moments to react to
it's a super fun movie subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button keep a lookout
for our interview with the screenwriter
looking forward to talking with him
see you guys soon